and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a our tonight review man of
steel I am pissed I'm a pleased at all
I've heard one planet Houston was
planning the Superman reboot and you can
imagine how filled with Glee I was when
I heard that General Zod was going to be
in it well guess who wasn't in it
General Zod instead who did they get to
play his part some wonderful
impersonator with a mo Howard haircut
I found this especially surprising
myself with the director was Zack Snyder
a director so obsessed with the male
form that half the machinery in this
movie looks like male parts keeping in
mind this information how is it I was
not chosen for the part this is all
natural zort
this material is skin tight to show off
my perfection the actor in this movie is
dressed like a tank trying to be a monk
because of this I've decided to
completely sabotage this movie you heard
right sabotage that's why I assure you
that this Superman movie will be one of
the Wars Superman movies you will ever
see that number three or four bad I
can't work miracles but still this one
will be pretty bad for example I broke
the wrist of every cinematographer on
this movie guaranteeing that there will
be absolutely no still shots in the
entire film
oh you thought the Hunger Games
shaky-cam was bad get ready for catching
Parkinson's on top of that using my
incredible sucking powers get your mouse
out of that comment box I managed to
completely suck away all of the actors
acting abilities any Adams bland
Laurence Fishburne and Russell Crowe and
Kevin Costner you know I didn't have to
do that to them on top of that I also
managed to catch up with the film's
editor using my incredible Zord muscles
which I call hustles copyrighted Zod I
managed to beat his brains out so
severely that he's got short-term memory
loss because of this he completely
forgot the order in which he edited this
movie when Superman lands as a baby on
earth he suddenly a fisherman
whenever he's about to talk to Lois Lane
he'll suddenly be 12 and whenever
there's a moment that's about to develop
any character whatsoever action scene
tornados buses falling explosions fake
knees attacking it'll jump around so
much you make more of an emotional
connection to your popcorn on top of
that I laser I think the original
writers of this film thus forcing them
to instead get the creators of Batman
Begins in the Dark Knight who have done
nothing but try to recreate Batman
Begins in the Dark Knight recall the
same thing happening to their home alone
writer
thus the movie is totally convinced
that's trying to tell the story of
Batman again except I was even more
devious every time the writers would
finish a scene that they put together
I immediately erased their memories yes
you notice how that speech about what it
means to be Superman seems to be the
only dialogue that goes throughout the
entire thing that's because they kept
forgetting that they wrote it a million
times there's another example of that at
the very end
by the way spoilers I'm supposed to do
that where Superman has faked me in a
headlock and faked me is using his laser
I think he's to kill some people the way
it's set up that people could of course
dock or duck run away there's about five
different ways out of it and Superman
breaks his neck another flaw and not
hiring me nobody can break this sucker
Superman screams and anger that he
actually had to take another life and
any other movie this would obviously
torture him and stay with him for the
rest of his life to be forgotten in the
next scene that's right it's like it
never happened because in the writers
mind it did never happen ohoo you're
mean one mr. Zod of course some of you
might be wondering how could i erase
their memories well you know that memory
erasing kiss that was done in Superman
too
let's just leave it at that so now you
know what happens when you don't hire
General Zod to play General Zod I will
ruin your movie forever and make it
cinematic poison and I know that for
many of you the movie was totally
destroyed and some argue those changes
actually made it better for some reason
which is very reassuring to me it shows
you planet whose teens will be much
easier to take over that I originally
intended next you'll be telling me you
like the purge as for me I think I've
destroyed any credibility that DC Comics
used to have the time has come to move
to Marvel and see if I can get a role
playing the grape jelly thing adventures
too until then hey who locked the door I
was never here don't make me memory
erase kiss you it was a pushes to the
pool
well anyway oh my god this is your
greatest movie ever is it what are you
going hey hey come back to me we going
wait a minute I'm just getting started
it was those debris in the ground did I
fall through the ceiling again
you